Neal: The story of a loving dad
from Northern California who happens
to be pretty good at math,
but who knew that when he was asked
to help his nieces get through a
few equations, he would end up providing
the answer for tens of thousands
of students everywhere.
Neal Karlinsky with
our Person of the Week.
Sal Kahn is a 33 year old stay-at-home dad
who spends his mornings
with his 18 month old, and the rest
of his day crammed inside a walk-in closet
running a school like no other.
Sal: The exponent here is a
variable. It's not a constant.
If it was just a constant,
we would be able to use the power rule,
but we can't do that.
Neal: Why are you in a closet?
Sal: This location in our house is
as far away as you can get
from my son while he's
screaming is the simple answer.
Neal: The free videos are anything
but flashy just a doodling electronic pen
on a blackboard and
Khan's enthusiastic voice,
but they've grown into one of the world's
most popular educational websites,
tutorials that are seen on
average 70,000 times a day.
Sal: To start, one plus one,
move at their own pace,
pause and repeat videos as necessary.
They can do exercises,
keep doing those exercises
until they are 100% proficient.
Neal: The thing is Kahn
was a hedge fund manager
until a year ago and these lessons were
just for his nieces.
They went viral by accident growing
so popular that Khan quit his job
to run the Khan Academy,
a collection of 1800 mostly
nine minute tutorials.
To say they've caught
on, is an understatement.
Bill: There's a website that I've
just been using with my kids recently
called Khan Academy.
Neal: Bill Gates and his son are two
of Khan's most loyal students addicted
to his easy to understand presentations
that can be repeated until
the student really gets it.
Do you think he's a good teacher?
Male: He's a really good teacher.
Neal: After talking with students
around the world on Skype,
I decided to try it with
my seven year old, Max.
Does this make sense?
Max: Uh huh. (affirmative)
Neal: Did you know that?
Max: No, I didn't.
Neal: What is it about the
way he talks that you like?
Max: I don't know. It's
just kind of a mathy talk.
Neal: It's a mathy talk?
Max: Yeah.
Neal: That's good, and you understand him.
Max: Uh huh. (affirmative)
Sal: I get a sense that it's working
because it is so basic
that people really feel
like it's a human talking to a human.
Neal: Bill Gates favorite teacher
is available to anyone who wants him free.
So we choose Sal Kahn.
He's received millions
of dollars in donations to keep
those simple lessons coming.